une histoire de dingues qui s'est passé
ce week-end c'est un tchèque de 26 ans
au nom de hunza qui est fan de barbie
jusque là rien de fou sauf que le gars
qui la dépasse elle a dépensé en trois
ans près de 20000 euros pour ressembler
comme deux gouttes d'eau à la poupée
barbie
le résultat je vous le montrer c'est pas
ou fait feu on aurait pu mettre moins
regardés voilà il était beau gosse était
beau gosse et regardez ce qu'il est
devenu
vous avez des images qui n'a il a dit à
la la la la la à hilla d'élèves sainte
odile quintin se régaler alors mais tu
mets des mecs de sully pour pêcher du
poisson
justement vous si vous deviez faire de
la chirurgie pour ressembler à quelqu'un
vous dit tout sur les réseaux sociaux à
qui vous vouliez voudriez ressembler
benjamin castaldi n'y aurait pas
beaucoup de travail à faire je pense que
brad pitt c'est ce que je prenais un
serpent
[Rires]
ça parce que valérie bénaïm mois pareils
a pas beaucoup de taf mais je faucheuse
on est à ça emilie ratatosk et moi
lorsque s'emballe de plus et willy
ratage lagardère vont sortir si les
mêmes et vous devriez faire la même peau
coup d'ailleurs
ouais ça vous va hyper bien ben ouais
franchement jean michel maire moi c'est
un voeu pieux évidemment mais j'aimerais
bien vous ressemble et voilà
[Applaudissements]
après il faut savoir dire à un mélange
de chevalier laspalès
mais si nous on dirait / ap de celui qui
était à la recherche de mesrine le
commissaire broussard incroyable et
qu'est-ce qu'on est vilain tourner dans
son ensemble oui
non parce que vous vous êtes très beau
comme ça c'est paris mois n'est pas
besoin de venir et moi qui vivais
novelli merci oui moi ce serait megan
fox alors est ce qu'on peut avoir la
précieuse en faire le tout de suite le
truc parce que on aimerait bien voir
voilà la photo avant elle c'est mieux
assurée
c'est bonnet blanc blanc bonnet d'âne
les marches le monde remonte à jal a les
cheveux qui démarre ici à l'exil
rafael nadal puissant et sympathique le
contraire de moi
[Applaudissements]
nadal mais bon dépression mes frères
c'est pas vingt mille aulas et familiale
mais quel rapport
c'est un rêve ah mais oui mais oui je
suis confiant je confirme je copiais
bureau qu'isabelle alors qu'il se serait
temps par messieurs alors j'ai choisi
des films wespiser pourquoi pouvoir on
va voir
ouais on attend a franchement j'espère
delphine wespiser sera aussi belle que
vous à votre âge vous dis ah non il ya
des chansons j'espère que c'est un gros
plus il attendait ses patientes ou
encore là dans un siècle mais aussi
d'affiner la mais vous êtes magnifique
temps parce que quand je la vois là
franchement n'avait rien à lui envier
magnifique lille est sérieux bernard
montiel willy bernard montiel non alors
moi je vais vous dire j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi j'ai vu un peu tous ces beaux
mecs on voit partout et enfin je me suis
dit que le mieux c'était moi
[Rires]
mais
je suis beaucoup plus sérieux je pense
plutôt à henry cavill
j'aimerais ressort à qui jean way pour
moi c'est vrai on a souvent dit que je
ressemblais à henri kabyle ville de
kabylie à l'est géraldine danon un sex
symbol à l'opposé de moi j'ai une blonde
platine temps court bain avec une sorte
de sex-appeal un sens d'axel bonnie
clyde barrow
ah ouais bah ouais bah oui mais c'est
pas l1 oui ça vous fait divers bien vrai
marilyn monroe et l'ont pas ils ont pas
mal changé de fond travail à moitié et
vous alors même chose un sex-symbol
n'ont pas trait être tom cruise away des
abdos en béton au 10 mai scotto
extrêmement fort et elle le prouve la
casca ce serait je vois là dans mission
impossible
ouais ouais c'est le clermontois comme
qu'on vient nous voir on embrasse tous
les dockers montferrand d'ailleurs et
bah écoutez franchement bravo vous avez
fait les très très très bon choix et
vous ce serait quoi ré moi ce serait
vous si je reste debout ressembler et
j'espère que ça va arriver un jour mais
avec grand plaisir je mettrai tous les
moyens qu'il faut